[Music]
breaking news this Friday night the U.S
shoots down a mysterious object high in
the sky the object was flying at an
altitude of 40 000 feet and posed a
reasonable threat
a Canadian team's life-saving role in
the earthquake zone nobody's given up
plus a closer look at turkey's Building
Safety standards
hiring is free how Canada's job market
is exceeding expectations big time
focusing on a fight for democracy they
feel like it's moving towards a
dictatorship at Canadian
photojournalists mission in Peru
and it's not only for your grandparents
how pickleball is now a hit for all ages
and the controversy of the games serving
up
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin once again in turkey and Syria
where news grows more Grim with each
passing hour over 23 000 people are now
known to have died the World Health
Organization is warning up a secondary
crisis now without clean water there's
concern disease will spread and
according to the U.N 874
000 people are in urgent need of food
thousands are still missing under
collapsed buildings but even four days
later there are still a few Miracles
taking place in the mountains of ruin
but scars and blood stains on his face
this father who lost his wife and
daughter has just found his 18 month old
son in Syria
after getting over the shock of the
moment he greets his toddler with a kiss
the baby's caregivers use social media
to find his family posting video of the
toddler eating a banana in hospital they
said adoption is not allowed we have to
give time for people
and in Turkey this 10-day old baby was
pulled from a collapsed building after
being buried for 90 hours
his name is yaoos which means brave in
Turkish Rescuers also saved his mother
now rescues like these are very rare but
they are giving fuel to Crews working
around the clock in the bitter cold to
find survivors today a search team from
Canada helped rescue a woman in Turkey
trapped for over a hundred hours under a
concrete building Jackson cross goes
there but before we go to him we want to
warn you some of the images are
disturbing
they found her in a collapsed apartment
building a woman who'd survived four
days trapped what's happened is the
bottom three or four floors and all
these buildings have all collapsed and
the top floors have just kind of settled
on top of them so she was in one of
those floors so there's probably about a
two foot Gap a search and rescue team
from British Columbia was part of the
international mission to pluck her to
safety using tools to locate life in a
sea of Destruction we got some camera an
acute acoustic sensing equipment
um so we're just trying to detect and
and see what we can see and then go from
there it took six hours to dig her out
all that matters is that she survived
no small miracle in adiaman a city of
dust and death the damage here in
adiaman is absolutely catastrophic you
can see multiple searches taking place
at the same time block after block after
block is filled with collapsed buildings
heavy machines Claw at the endless
Rubble
sometimes they fall silent so that
Searchers can listen for survivors but
it is the Dead who are most often found
so many their bodies go uncollected in
the streets this man wept and wondered
why no one would come for his daughter
and son
the pace of the search is both
frustrating and heartbreaking time is
running out to find survivors visiting
the city turkey's president admitted the
task is simply too large
it is a fact that we have not been able
to respond as fast as we had hoped he
said
for the Canadian Searchers there's no
time to rest no time to savor the
miracle of the day we're still here
we're still putting the time in and
nobody's given up it's on to the next
collapse site in a city where so little
is left standing
Jackson prosco Global News ariyama and
turkey
there's also so little of standing in
Northern Syria the U.N Refugee agency
says more than 5 million people have
been left homeless by Monday's powerful
earthquakes many of the affected areas
are under blockades imposed by the
regime of Bashar al-assad in a carefully
choreographed tour the president saw
hard-hit areas firsthand today he says
he will now allow Aid to be delivered to
rebel-held Regions but as Redmond
Shannon reports it'll be a huge
challenge to even get there
Mass Graves being dog for earthquake
victims in Northern Syria
a lot of children's bodies come in but
no one knows anything about them so we
bury them as Anonymous says this
volunteer gravedigger
many of those who survived could hardly
be described as fortunate
my whole family died I can't believe
this says Yusef in Aleppo so many
syrians haven't just lost families but
they're homes too it is very difficult
to describe the layers of suffering and
destruction that I'm witnessing here in
Aleppo and in some Civil War affected
regions there is nowhere left to go in
the middle of winter and little Aid to
help aid only gets through one
restricted corridor from Turkey on
Friday the regime of President Bashar
al-assad said it will now allow the
delivery of humanitarian Aid into Rebel
areas
on his first visit to an affected region
Assad lashed out at the West for its
sanctions against his regime even though
Aid had technically been exempt from
those sanctions the reality is that
there's there's no possibility of
providing any kind of relief any kind
without engaging with political
questions on Friday 14 Aid trucks
crossed into Syria from Turkey but much
much more help is needed ultimately the
welfare of so many syrians May rely on
the west and Assad finding some level of
trust quickly Redmond Shannon Global
News London
the images that you see from Turkey in
Syria cannot fully capture the vast
scale of the disaster the number of
people displaced the number of homes and
buildings destroyed turkey is prone to
earthquakes and has updated its building
standards in recent years structures
that meet earthquake building codes are
designed to remain standing long enough
for people to escape but this week
thousands of buildings collapsed in an
instant and many more are no longer safe
Eric Sorensen explores why
foreign
for every person found alive more than a
hundred hours after the earthquakes
there are thousands now desperate to
stay alive individuals without families
families with little food and no shelter
in the cold weather in one town after
another
what will happen to these people he says
will the government look after us or not
we're all staying Outdoors now how will
this end so many buildings have utterly
collapsed and there aren't enough
machines to move all the rubble this man
points to the structural damage
buildings like his made of concrete too
brittle against the violent movements of
an earthquake
this house is uninhabitable says it's
fractured there's no hope that kind of
Devastation spans hundreds of kilometers
along the east Anatolian fault line the
first earthquake was the strongest in
Turkey in more than 80 years the second
major Quake a short time later followed
by dozens of aftershocks where the
tectonic plates push along the fault
line pressure builds until what's called
a strike slip a sudden horizontal
release on the surface buildings can
pancake that aren't properly reinforced
natural Engineers say steel
reinforcement can deform to keep
buildings from instantaneous collapse
but many of turkey's structures appear
to have been largely concrete although
turkey has building codes very much in
line with North American Standards if
they are designing to the code minimum
then they are designed to be heavily
damaged and the building are not
supposed to collapse so much the goal
for the building codes providing the
minimum safety so people can get out in
Carmen Mara scores of buildings were
reduced to Rubble next to buildings that
withstood the Quake critics say too many
buildings were not made safe or built
properly
the country was unprepared for this says
this opposition leader despite the
government of President erdogan
collecting billions in earthquake taxes
he says
lucky are the ones receiving food and
accommodation intent for the moment the
urgency remains finding those who've
survived but the crisis that will
persist is shelter because so many
structures have collapsed and so many
more are still standing cannot be
trusted Eric Sorensen Global News
to Laval Quebec now a community still
devastated days after that deadly bus
crash into a daycare center today a
special church service was held in the
Montreal suburb to honor the two
children who died and to pray for those
who were injured Sharia Israeli was
there today and she has more on the
anguish and the push for answers behind
this senseless tragedy
rows of stuffed animals line the altar
of a church in Laval the pain is shared
but for the priests leading the sermon
it's personal
it's me we're baptized that little boy
and three years after he's dead
what I can say
father Michelle Bouchard is now
preparing for that little boy's funeral
next week
he was killed along with another child
when a Laval Transit bus rammed into
their daycare on Wednesday in a crash
Witnesses describe as deliberate both of
the victims were just four years old not
answer but support
because there's no answer
and in the absence of answers the agony
is only Amplified I constantly
I'm thinking of those parents never
being able to hold the child
community members filled the pews to
honor the children and the six others
who were injured it's hard to cover in
like my granddaughter is four years old
this church is just a few minutes away
from the crash site it's become a
meeting place for people in Laval to pay
their respects and offer condolences one
note left here describes the community's
sadness as infinite
it's very sad she says it's simply
inexplicable
transit driver piagni Saint ammo has
been charged with two counts of
first-degree murder he's scheduled to
appear in court next Friday it's not
clear if the 51 year old had any
connection to the daycare
along with the flowers and toys White
flags are popping up in Laval daycares
are hanging them in their Windows as a
reminder these places should be safe
havens and never the scene of a crime
tariya isri Global News Laval
the Canadian labor market has defined
expectations with a blowout January for
job creation statistics Canada says 150
000 jobs were added last month
economists were only expecting 15 000
jobs it was the fifth straight month of
gains in employment but as David Akin
reports a hot economy could be a problem
for employers and those hoping for lower
interest rates
for these students learning welding
techniques the future looks pretty
bright I don't think it's going to be a
problem for me getting a job because
there seems to be a lot of people who
who want to hire you well I'd say an
eight to ten thousand welders are being
trained at this moment in Canada which
is not even close to fill the Gap that
we need
but of course it's not just welders oh
it's it's an incredibly hot labor market
right now for uh for those looking for
work uh we see a lot of demand from
employers and this is across a wide
range of Industries a wide range of
sectors those layoffs you may have heard
of it big tech companies like Google and
Microsoft well other tech companies are
busy hiring Bell Canada for example is
looking for a thousand high-tech skilled
workers and more we are also bringing in
450 new grads into the business with a
focus of course on diversity this is
both getting more women into the
business as well as bipoff Talent
the latest evidence of that hot labor
Mark came Friday in the jobs report from
statistics Canada the headline was 150
000 new jobs but that included 121
000 full-time jobs the employment rate
for women hit an all-time high at 82
percent and wages were up 4 and a half
percent compared to a year earlier so
we've been talking about for the last 12
months higher interest rates High
inflation possible recession Global
slowdown uh nothing's been positive news
and yet somehow the job market continues
to defy expectations but overall I would
say all things considered the economy
has been very resilient and and we're
bending but hasn't hasn't broken yet
that said the Bank of Canada may take a
look at this red hot labor market and
see inflationary pressures and that
experts say increases the odds that the
bank might raise interest rates further
to cool this hot economy Farah
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you David we
have some breaking news now this
afternoon U.S national security
officials announced another suspicious
object was shot down after it was
detected flying over Alaska yesterday
it entered into U.S airspace on February
9th uh we we sent up aircraft to assess
what it was the decision was made that
it posed a reasonable threat to civilian
air traffic the president uh gave the
order to take it down and we took it
down
unlike the Chinese surveillance balloon
shot down last week the Pentagon says
this latest object was flying at a much
lower altitude forty thousand feet the
cruising altitude for most commercial
planes and the size was also smaller was
the size of a small car its capabilities
purpose and origin are still unclear and
tonight Canada's defense minister is
confirming this object did not enter
Canadian airspace
Russia's new onslaught of attacks in
Ukraine coming up what's being targeted
and the fears of what will come next
[Music]
Russia ramped up its offensive in
Southeastern Ukraine today unleashing a
new wave of missile and drone strikes
against energy infrastructure sites and
civilian targets according to Ukraine's
Air Force Russian forces fired 71 cruise
missiles of which 61 were shot down its
feared Russia is planning another
assault as early as next week ahead of
the one-year anniversary of its
full-scale invasion
and the war is being cited as one of the
reasons for political upheaval in
neighboring Moldova moldova's president
has accepted prime minister Natalia
gavrieliza's resignation a pro-western
leader she blamed her exits on the
economic instability and political
turmoil from Russia's aggression and it
happened just hours after Moldova
claimed a Russian missile targeting
Ukraine had violated its airspace with
the war happening on its border Moldova
has been struggling with Russia reducing
its energy supplies and an influx of
Ukrainian refugees
Global News will Air a special on
February 25th to mark one year since the
full-scale Russian invasion of Ukraine
[Music]
political protests ahead we speak with a
Canadian photographer in the heart of
Peru's fight for democracy
[Music]
Peru's political crisis a deadly
Crackdown on demonstrators is deepening
tonight two months after the country's
former president was arrested
ousted and then replaced at least 58
people have been killed since the
clashes between anti-government
protesters and police erupted tonight
arnita Garcia speaks to a Canadian in
the heart of the protests
[Music]
Canadian photojournalist Michael Bednar
is on a mission he didn't expect I came
to do a story on the quechuan culture
and the indigenous cultures of the Andes
but things took a turn when then
president Pedro Castillo was arrested
accused of staging a coup and his former
running mate Dina biluarte took office I
arrived in Cusco on December December
7th the day the coup was started and now
that indigenous quechua group he came to
photograph is at the center of the
deadly demonstrations he says his images
help capture what's really happening the
people who are fighting feel like
they're fighting for democracy because
they feel like it's moving towards a
dictatorship he says the group is
calling for elections to be held this
year and a referendum on a new
constitution meanwhile Peru called on
citizens this week to report social
media users suspected of supporting or
inciting acts of terrorism the majority
of the people are simple people who are
not terrorists he traveled with them on
a dangerous two-day Journey from their
Community to Lima where many are staying
in spaces like this one surviving off
donated food and supplies University of
Toronto student Andrea Roman has just
arrived in her home country which she
believes has reached a boiling point a
general kind of like assembly of workers
of Peru has called for a general strike
a case of four days and they haven't
done that for the last 20 years there
were demonstrations like this one across
Peru Thursday commemorating the 18 lives
lost in a single day last month they're
implying that indigenous people are
going to be treated as terrorists
therefore violence is allow against them
University of Alberta Professor Jorge
Sanchez Perez who was born and raised in
Peru has a warning about the racial and
economic tensions we live in a system
where exploitation has become the rule
and if we don't face that fact in
different parts of the world what's
happening in Peru can be replicated
I think it's important to have
international eyes on what's Happening
Bednar who sold his home and many of his
belongings in British Columbia for this
trip remains committed to showing the
conflict to the world through his lens
Global News
[Music]
sport for all next
it's been a sport that's been around for
decades but now pickleball is considered
the fastest growing sport in North
America but pickleball isn't without
controversy as Candace Daniel explains
noise concerns and a lock of facilities
are causing tension between players and
communities
there's something infectious about being
on this court pickleball is just so
unique in that way where it just brings
everybody together pickleball craze has
grabbed a hold of millions of people
across North America including Brad
Chapman from Calgary who hopes to turn
pro one day
that adrenaline rush you get from
fighting for the win and that kind of
thing is just super exciting
pickleball's explosion in popularity has
led to Growing Pains there aren't enough
places to play so pickleballers have had
to get creative and turn empty parking
lots and outdoor courts into areas to
play causing friction with traditional
Sports what we're seeing is that there
are tennis courts that haven't been used
some of the facilities their courts
might not be filled and they're changing
some of their tennis courts into
pickleball courts here in Victoria some
players would really like to have all of
the tennis courts marked for pickleball
but we need to focus on getting our own
space the battle for space has led to
another problem
the sound the ball makes when hit has
triggered clashes between players and
residents noise complaints have resulted
in court cases fines and even bans last
spring the city of Victoria barred
pickleballers from an outdoor tennis
court over noise concerns so Connie
McCann and her Club held a pickleball
protest at City Hall to fight the
decision
[Applause]
the city did the right thing they found
us some dedicated courts Connie's Club
also raised money to build a sound
barrier to try and mitigate the noise on
the outdoor courts with more than a
million Canadians now playing pickleball
what's needed is more dedicated space
and solutions to ease those tensions
pharah
thank you Candace and that's global
national for this Friday night I'm Farah
Nasser and on behalf of our whole crew I
want to thank you so much for spending
part of your Friday evening with us
tonight's your Canada is Kamloops
British Columbia until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]